A major disease can be debilitating for anyone.
However, optimism and tenacity can help overcome many associated challenges.
Kristine Barnett's 15-year-old son named Jacob was diagnosed with a severe form of autism...
...when he was just a toddler.
The child had encountered lost speech and psychologists initially believed he would never talk again.
The concerned mom placed Jacob in a developmental program...
...which included meetings with numerous therapists.
Although he was different from the other children his own age,...
...Kristine noticed his high intelligence level.
She took him on trips to a planetarium and sat outside, watching the stars with him,...
...encouraging Jacob to take on hobbies and interests.
And she also put a stop to the therapist meetings.
She took on the role of teaching and educationally interacting with him on her own.
Amazingly, by the age of three, Jacob began talking again.
Six months later, he taught himself how to read.
These days, the now teenage boy is working on obtaining a PhD.
Kristine says, "If somebody had drive, they can accomplish anything."